je n'ai qu'un mot à vous donner
pénet il vous ouvrira les bonnes portes
et parfois aussi les mauvaises
attention en l'utilisant
[Musique]
pour faire mon travail
il faut que j'ai une idée de ce qui le
menace d'après ce que j'ai compris
nous essayons d'éviter la troisième
guerre mondiale
je ne vois pas d'apocalypse la pire que
ça je crois savoir que vous vous
intéressez un certain citoyens russes
pourquoi faire appel à moi
donné à le savoir
il peut communiquer avec l'avenir
voyage temporel non inversion visé est
pressé sur la détente
vous me direz pas la balle pour la
retrouver
bon j'en ai trouvé là on va essayer de
suivre le rythme
notre devoir transcende l'intérêt
national
c'est une question de survie
et audacieux audacieux ça me va je
croyais que vous diriez cinglé
c'est ici que nos mondes s'entrechoquent
comment hameury font mourir vieux pays
vous n'avez pas choisi le bon métier
[Musique]
s'est passé quoi ici
ça s'est pas encore passé
il ya des gens dans l'avenir qui ont
besoin de nouvelles qui ont besoin de
tes net
nous devons les sauver ici et maintenant
avec cette inversion de cours du temps
le fait qu'on soit ici
maintenant ça veut pas dire que c'est
jamais arrivé
vous voulez écrasé un avion mais pas
depuis les airs arrêter de dramatiser
bon un avion de quelle taille ce
poids-là légèrement dramatique